well we're not too behind schedule so
let's see if we can get ourselves back
on track here that was an extraordinary
session and I'm looking forward to
moderating the next extraordinary
session one of once again thank
everybody for coming thank mayor Dinkins
for hosting us today as he's done over
the last almost 15 years on this policy
forum I'm not sure if everybody's aware
of the fact this is the 20th anniversary
of Mayor Dinkins election to the mayoral
T the first african-american mayor of
the city of New York he's not here to
accept his accolades he's on his way in
but everybody knows what a
transformative an important moment that
was in New York City's history I still
like to talk about the gorgeous mosaic
because I think you got that right our
next panel and before we start I just
want to say thank you once again to the
Rockefeller Foundation and seat before
hosting us today and also to welcome
lieutenant governor basil Patterson
who's here with us very much happy to
see you and have you and all the and all
of the former commissioners of the
Jenkins administration and current
commissioners of the city of New York
who have joined us for the forum today
and of course deputy mayor Barbara Fife
from the Dinkins administration who's
also here with us today this afternoon's
final panel is a reflection on New York
City and the economic recovery agenda
for the metro region and really the role
Washington has played or has not played
in helping us toward this economic
recovery and I have to say I
we couldn't have found three more
articulate intelligent and creative New
Yorkers to lead us in this panel today
and it's my pleasure to introduce all
three of them and then ask them to step
up and share their thinking with us and
hopefully we will have some time for
questions at the end of the panel I
would first like to introduce on my far
left deputy mayor robert Lieber Robert
Lieber is in the probably most
critically important role as the city
emerges from the current national
recession he is the current deputy mayor
for economic development under Mayor
Michael Bloomberg and he began this
position in February of 2007 actually he
was named head of President of new york
city's Economic Development Corporation
then and I think probably didn't realize
that he would soon become deputy mayor
of economic development in January 2008
I know that Mayor Bloomberg could not
have found a more able and as I said
more creative person to lead us in this
position he is really responsible for
creating jobs and building the economic
capacity in the five boroughs the
Department of small business services
the city's Economic Development
Corporation the planning department the
Department of Finance and New York City
and company all report to him it's a new
configuration of agencies all designed
to really kick start and boost and
maintain this economic development
project in economic development projects
in New York City he is right now has his
hands full I think with will at Point
lower Manhattan Hudson Yards one hundred
and twenty fifth street jamaica and
Coney Island just to name some of the
few projects that he is involved in
right now and spearheading deputy mayor
Lieber previously served as managing
director of Lehman Brothers where he was
global head of real estate
investment and banking institutional
investor magazine I love this one Bob
named him named him for deal of the year
and financier of the year in 2005 he is
received his BA from the University of
Colorado and an MBA from the wharton
school at the University of Pennsylvania
it's nothing just another example of New
York City attracting the best and the
brightest from all over the country
thank you for joining us today we really
appreciate it second David Jones most of
you in this room know David and but i'm
going to introduce him anyway because
it's really a sincere pleasure to be
standing here in introducing david jones
who has really given his heart his soul
if not his life to public service in New
York City and he is really a paramount
example for any of my students in the
room today look at David Jones career
and if you're lucky you get to do one
tenth of what he's done he is currently
the president and chief executive
officer of the community service society
in New York City a nonpartisan
not-for-profit organization that
promotes the economic advancement and
full civic participation for low-income
New Yorkers I love this in his bio it
says he's an outspoken advocate for
low-income New Yorkers I'd say it
differently I'd say he is probably the
best advocate the working people in this
city could have speaking truth to power
every day every opportunity that he can
and making the rest of the city I think
a better place that the consequence of
his work he did serve in government as
the Commissioner for the Department of
Youth our current Commissioner for the
Department of youth and community
development of fear Genie Maghreb and
I'm sure that things have changed
somewhat since you've been there but
really I think set the stage for this is
one of the most creative and I think
progressive of the city agencies now
under Mayor Michael Bloomberg I hope the
rest of the commissioners are not here
to hear me but everybody knows that's
what I think and finally david has also
served as chair of the of the board of
Carver federal savings bank so has been
both in the public and private sector he
received his juris doctor from Yale and
he has a bachelor's degree from Wesleyan
and we are really also grateful for you
being with us today David and I'm
looking forward to a exciting and feisty
conversation here finally finally left
but not least of course Catherine while
president and CEO of the partnership for
New York City Cathy also doesn't really
need much introduction for most people
in this room and she's she's just had I
think one of the most extraordinary
careers in bridging the differences
between the public private and nonprofit
sector and actually figuring out how to
make them all work together this is not
an easy fee for many of you who've tried
to do it and I think most people don't
do it effectively and this is as I said
something that now is a model a national
model in which other cities come to New
York to try and learn from Cathy on how
she has run the partnership and really
made it a civically engaged constructive
and creative force for policy in New
York the partnership as its described
works with government labor and the
not-for-profit sectors to build a
stronger New York with a focus on
education infrastructure and the economy
and under Cathy's leadership it's done
all of that and more
with far-reaching policy reports
behind-the-scenes negotiations pulling
things basically out of the fire that we
thought would collapse there's Kathy
they are making sure that people
actually work together I you know I I
don't know how you do with Kathy I
really don't um I don't think there's
anybody that can do it as effectively as
she has and you know what she comes from
Madison Wisconsin so go no I don't have
how that happened that what explains it
I think maybe going to stay in Olaf's
college or maybe because you actually
live in Brooklyn and not in Manhattan
but Kathy brings her expertise her
energy and Hershiser intelligence all
for the better of this city and again
these are really three of the pillars of
our civil society in New York and I'm
just thrilled they're up here at
Columbia helping us celebrate Mayor
Dinkins 20th anniversary and we'll be
speaking for us on this issue that's I
think so important to us how to get our
economy going again and had her
essentially recut recover and continue
that recovery through the 21st century
thank you very much in advance and I'm
going to begin our panel by calling on
deputy mayor lever thank you everybody
thank you wester and Mayor Dinkins for
hosting this and having me here today
one of the other things that I am
particularly proud of that I have been
able to do was I had the opportunity to
also serve as an adjunct professor at
Columbia several years ago teaching a
real estate capital markets class so it
that was really the most fun and I still
find it interesting that almost 15 years
ago now I still run into students of
mine and we'll see on the street who are
doing different things and so trying to
connect with students and make some kind
of an impact hopefully positive and what
they can do was really very very
fulfilling and when I started in this
job three years ago I had no idea what
an interesting trip that was going to be
in
two different cycles and what's happened
in our economy when i started i retired
from lehman brothers in 2006 the market
was at an all-time high everything was
going great and here we are three years
later we're certainly in a slightly
different position and i think is we've
been with some and summarize and talk a
little bit today about what the stimulus
package is done and we're at stake in
new york city and where we think we are
today and where we're going to go as we
move forward in some of the critical
aspects and critical challenges that we
face as we go but and I think we the
good news is that we're kind of work I
think we're through the worst of this
now I think we have seen kind of the
bottom or we're close to the bottom and
we see things starting to pick up or at
least things on the horizon one of the
one of the things that we look at that
we are very troubled though is is the
unemployment rate unemployment rate is
up over from where it was last year
about three percent higher than it was
last year and even up a little bit from
November unemployment rate Tim seems to
be a lagging indicator it tends to be
and is calculated in different ways but
it you know it's still a very very
important part of what I think it
underlies the overall economic recovery
in the nation and certainly here in New
York City and I think even though in any
job loss is is too much there are some
encouraging signs today we have job
losses today that about a hundred and
forty thousand people that's the bad
news that the good news is that that's
about a hundred and thirty thousand less
than what we really projected at this
stage of the game so while it's been
tumultuous time we actually have seen
less job losses than we expected and I
think also you look at a couple of
different things that have happened but
i think the the arrow program or the
stimulus package as far as the way we
track it and you can see it on steam
tracker dot gov but we've projected or
counted about 27,000 almost 28,000 jobs
have been directly created or retained
because of the stimulus funding and
what's taking place here in New York
City so that's been a very positive
contributor certainly I think another
part for us given new york city's you
know concentration around the finance
business around the bank
the insurance securities business and
stuff that the tarp program that was put
in place a year ago has also done a lot
to support the underlying businesses in
the securities industry our job losses
in the security sector about 33,000
again too many more than we want
certainly but certainly less than the 60
thousand or so that we had originally
forecasted so you know financial
services is down not as bad as we
thought it was going to be but still
materially bad but we do see other
sectors that are actually doing better
than when we had anticipated and I think
part of this is a lot about planning I'm
certainly going to give my boss a lot of
credit for planning since I've been here
we've been through seven different sets
of cuts in terms of our budget process
to try and bring things in a line
anticipate what was coming but I think
when we look at the stimulus package
overall it certainly was a really
important shot in the arm for New York
City because in many respects it really
gave us time bought as time the ability
to stabilize things to widen the safety
net and maintain the essential services
that are so critical to keeping the city
together and to do this without having
to substitute money that we would use
for long-term investments in the future
it has provided a great cushion for what
we're trying to do overall the stimulus
package we contributed about five
billion dollars to New York City four
billion of this comes and expense money
and then another nine hundred and some
odd million comes in in capital money
but of the four billion dollars that
came and expense dollars to New York
City from the stimulus package the bulk
of that 3.6 out of four billion dollars
went to Medicaid relief and to education
so two very important fundamental
services for the city were protected
again largely from the four billion
dollars in expense dollars outside of
this four billion dollars was another
almost nine hundred million dollars that
went directly to food stamp recipients
again trying to
provide that safety net for New Yorkers
and what what this money has done is it
really helped us build upon some of the
the innovative any property programs
that we've developed to try and help New
Yorkers who are in particular need some
of it as the helping New Yorkers file
their earned income tax credits that
were almost a little over 850,000 eitc
returns filed in 2008 alone which saved
2.3 billion dollars we've also opened
five offices of the financial
empowerment offices that to help
low-income New Yorkers build their asset
base and learn ways to avoid the
predatory lending that was taking place
as well as money for child tax credits
again more than 50,000 New Yorkers
received more than 30 million intact in
child tax credit claims in the first
year alone and I think that it's
important to think about this though
when you look at the stimulus package
overall you know was originally
conceptualized I believe as an
infrastructure bill trying to build for
the long term for the future but for us
it was really you know it was critical
to be able to try and shore up the
city's position in the city's budget at
a particularly difficult time as I
mentioned the stimulus money went
largely that four billion dollars to
support education and and Medicaid costs
and they were so the bulk of the
infrastructure money really went not for
infrastructure but for basic essential
services here in the city there was some
nine hundred million dollars that went
for the infrastructure here but again so
it provides us the opportunity to be
able to use the money to support
essential services and we still have
money that we can use for infrastructure
as we go forward Kathy I promised that
I'd go through some of the numbers here
and overall but we we anticipate overall
from the stimulus about five billion
dollars in total and that breaks down
into eight different categories 2.1
billion of that is in the education that
I mentioned before Medicaid relief
provided another
point six billion dollars the
infrastructure dollars that we have
available to us were a little over nine
hundred million dollars money to help
stabilize vulnerable neighborhoods
accounted for about a hundred and ninety
million dollars public safety again one
of the most important things we have
here in New York was about 80 million
and then energy efficiency Health and
Human Services and Workforce Development
made up the balance of that funding here
so I think that again it bought us a
significant amount of time and gave us
the ability to think about moving
forward and I think the challenge for us
today is to make sure that New York City
and and the country can continue to
retain our position for long-term
competitiveness and and for growth so
when we think about New York City's
competitiveness and we think about
infrastructure we think about what are
the things that we can do today they're
going to make the biggest impact as we
go forward so in this mayor's
administration a lot of focus have been
on long-term capital programs long-term
infrastructure programs the extension of
the number seven train that the new york
city is paying for exclusively here not
the MTA over two billion dollars to
build that additional capacity and the
west side and the Hudson Yards
continuing the work to try and
accelerate the completion of the third
water tunnel you know again big
important long-term capital projects
that are going to see the fruits of
these investments not over the next two
to three years but over the next two to
three to four decades as new york city
continues to grow a capital commitments
for fiscal year ten we're continuing our
capital budget for 2010 was over 11
billion dollars which is a sixty-five
percent increase over was when Mayor
Bloomberg came into office here so again
making those investments today they're
going to have the ability to pay
dividends as we go forward I mentioned
there's 900 million that comes from the
stimulus package for infrastructure
we've already contracted for over 500
million of that a lot of that is going
for transportation projects
reconstruction of the Brooklyn Bridge
Park excuse me the Brooklyn Bridge on
ramps work at the ferry terminal insa
Staten Island we're also over 200
million dollars is going to the water
supply and wastewater treatment plants
and then over 400 million dollars again
into public housing we also have applied
and have been able to take advantage of
other aspects that come out of the
stimulus package including the
recoveries on excuse me the recovery
zone bond program and this is a program
that was distributed by the federal
government and by formula and we were
able to we were allocated a little over
120 million dollars and the economic
development corporation or EDC is
responsible for applying this 120
million dollars in different loans and
what we did is we set up an RFP process
where people could actually apply for
using this money and that the criteria
that we used around again around
infrastructure was looking at the
project's trying to make a determination
of how quickly that money could be put
to productive use how quickly you know
the shovel readiness aspect of this we
also these allocations were made in
economically distressed areas and then
also based on their overall financial
feasibility so in the first round we had
over 35 million dollars allocated to
projects in Brooklyn and Queens the
second round 60 well 70 million is in
process for four projects including the
cultural and arts center in Central
Harlem in 80,000 square foot
state-of-the-art medical office building
to be in the North Queen's Medical
Center an expanded parking structure for
the st. barnabas hospital in the bronx
again looking at ways that we can put
this money to work right away to create
jobs and to build infrastructure that
will give us the capacity as we move
forward in the future so i think when we
look at the 900 million that's come you
know in infrastructure and we think
about these initial projects the one
thing that but i think we need to
continue to think about as far as New
York City's own competitiveness is we
need to think a slightly more regional
here we tend to be very myopically
focused on the five boroughs or in our
own little areas here but we need to
think more about New York City's
competitiveness here in necessary
improvements in at the airports just the
FAA the tracking system that we use is
an antiquated system that's over 40
years old the technology and the
airplanes far exceeds the technology
that's on the ground to control them
which is kind of scary but we also need
to continue to think about mass transit
infrastructure improvements and looking
at different ways that we're going to be
able to accommodate the growth in our
population and reduce the overall
dependence on the automobile so very
important things as we continue to think
about the long-term perspective of New
York City we're also using 80 million
dollars targeting it to different kinds
of energy efficiency programs we've got
retrofitting city buildings we've made a
commitment to reduce the carbon
footprint in city buildings and we're
also creating a revolving loan fund for
the greater greener building plan which
is another way to encourage landlords
and tenants to make the approve meneses
ery to improve the efficiency of the
space that they occupy another critical
part for new york city in its long-term
competitiveness is our affordable
housing back in 2005 the mayor announced
the affordable housing program designed
to renovate or build 165,000 new units
just looking at the market today and
what's going on out there and last week
or two weeks ago in the state of the
city the mayor announced a 750 million
dollar fund that is going to be targeted
terms of trying to buy and to
rehabilitate distressed multifamily
properties and look at ways that we can
convert these properties into affordable
housing I mean you can see all around
projects that are part way through or
not completed or completed and haven't
been tented one of the things that we
really worry about or or even existing
buildings that took advantage of this
financing bubble over levered they don't
have the money available to keep the
buildings up to code
so we're very concerned about the
destabilizing effect of some of these
buildings on the neighborhoods and some
of the opportunities that we can bring
to bear to continue to create more
affordable housing out of some of the
existing supply and to continue to look
for ways to stabilize the neighborhoods
so the housing is going to continue to
be a very very important part of all
that we do going forward and it's a
particularly big challenges we look at
the market today one of the other things
Esther that you talked about my job and
its most simple basis is to create jobs
and expand the tax base so we've talked
a lot about the big real estate projects
that are out there whether it be hudson
yards or Willets Point or Coney Island
or lower manhattan or 125th street a big
part of that is kind of building the
capacity or building the supply so that
we can accommodate people as the city
grows we are also intensely focused
right now in creating the demand you
know economics the supply and demand
what we're trying to do now is create
more demand and create more jobs find
ways to get people working so that we
can occupy as much of the space as we
can and when we look at new york's kind
of competitive position overall what
makes this such a great city today
what's going to make it a great city as
we continue to move forward it's it's
it's clear that talent is our is our
greatest asset and in order for us to
really excel going forward we need to
continue to invest in our people in
looking back in our workforce one
centers last year we were actually able
to place more than 25,000 people who
were looking for work last year that was
up you know almost thirty percent from
where we were the prior year so despite
the downturn we were able to increase
those places dramatically and one of the
things that we're doing with stimulus
money is taking advantage of the
workforce one centers and the abilities
that we had through through our small
business services to create trying to
create sector specific initiatives
training programs that address the needs
of the businesses in the community and
the people who live there so whether it
be in the health care center that we've
announced with LaGuardia Community
College which we project 750 placements
or so over the first two years looking
for ways for patient
our technicians emts paramedics LPNs etc
these are you know good paying jobs and
and this is money that is very targeted
for specific uses also comes from some
of the money that we're able to get from
the stimulus package we also announced a
manufacturing sector center looking for
targeted manufacturing industrial jobs
particularly in Brooklyn looking at
different parts of the waterfront and
where we see technology and
manufacturing coming together to create
jobs and Brooklyn as well so we're
trying to find different ways to address
the specific needs of the businesses and
the communities and the people who live
there and using stimulus money to create
these training programs small businesses
you know employ more than fifty percent
of the New Yorkers actually work for
small businesses here and what we've
seen over the last two years is even
those small businesses that had really
the best best relationships with their
banks that had great credit records etc
you know found that the banks that they
had these relationships were unwilling
to continue to fund them as they went
forward here so EDC started what we call
the capital access loan program back
about a year ago and we're providing
loans and working with the local banks
to provide loans between 5,000 and 250
thousand dollars in terms of the loan
amounts to these small businesses so
that these businesses have the money
necessary to pay their employees to pay
to keep the utilities the lights and the
doors open here so that people can
continue to be employed as we move
forward here we've started a number of
other businesses and training centers
with the with the helps of the Calculon
foundation to support entrepreneurship
working with 11 Institute to Train
professionals into other industries and
get jobs that they can apply their
skills created business incubator spaces
from landlords that have surplus space
in their buildings today take advantage
of the market for office space that's
you know a little soft right now and
working with great landlords will use
that space and dedicated to people who
are starting their businesses and want
the Opera
to get up and get running here so
looking at different is whether the
fashion industry whether it be in the
technology business and media business
in the healthcare business all important
sectors for us in New York City and we
want to make sure people have the
requisite skills and the training and
match them up with job so we can get
people back to work so I think when the
topic of how has the stimulus money
affected New York City I think that you
know it really came at a very important
time for us which very much needed shot
in the arm that made sure that the city
stated in its position to be able to
provide the critical safety net to the
residents who are here but as we
continue to work our way through these
tough times I think it's important that
we continue to think about the city's
competitive position and we need to
continue to focus on making the
infrastructure investments that both
locally and regionally they keep the
city in as competitive position as we
can and we want to continue to look for
ways that we can match up the needs of
industries and the employees who are out
there looking for work and look for
different ways that we can do this in
different kinds of economic sectors not
just in financial services so that's
kind of an overview of the numbers and
the math in terms of how the stimulus
money has been applied and I think we
and you know we've been through tough
times I hope that we'll start to see
some pickup in the employment rates or
decline in the unemployment rates here
probably the second half of 2010 and
we'll see as we move for oh well thank
Thank You deputy mayor I'd like to call
on David Jones well I have to give
credit to David Dinkins certainly one of
my mentors over the years and basil
these are the guys you went to you as
part of your transition if you thought
about public service and they both were
extraordinarily helpful and many in this
room I know and worked with on a variety
of things and esters been a friend kathy
has been a friend for years I think
there was a comedy show on Monty Python
now for something completely different
and I'm sort of talking about that
another part of New York that has some
significant problems in this recession
that I think are going to be with us
even as the recovery gets underway and I
think it has implication obviously for
the individuals who are caught in this
problem as well as for the rest of the
city because I think this is going to be
a millstone on the city unless address
rather quickly and aggressively and I'll
talk what that's about before the
recession the New York City was in
pretty poor shape in terms of a number
of factors particularly income
inequality I think many people have
talked about this we have a dumbbell
shaped of a lot of low-wage workers and
some people making extraordinary money
at the top and very sort of an eroding
middle class so this was a shape before
this recession hit and basically we're
going to need a great deal of an
investment to work particularly with
low-wage workers and there alone nearly
a third of New Yorkers fall into that
category they are earning very low
income they're primarily non-unionized
workers and this recession actually is
their recession there's some analysis
that there is no recession for the
college educated in the city of New York
or in the rest of the nation this is a
recession primarily of people without
that's probably my daughter
turn this off so she shies away so we
keep tracked but this is primarily
recession of those with limited
educational skills and if you start to
tilt those numbers reflecting that the
ten point six percent we're talking
about immediately starts to double when
it comes to black workers without
particularly without high school and the
same for Latino workers in that respect
and those are the workers that are most
at risk in this recession and as you see
the 10.6 numbers what the other number
you have to reflect on in terms of when
the recovery actually with it low-wage
workers is the sharp reduction in hours
and wages because as the slow recovery
moves its way through the society the
employers are not going to start hiring
they're going to start bringing back
hours and increasing wages for their
existing workforce before they begin to
get into the unemployed and structurally
unemployed as they go forward let me let
me tell you why we're concerned about
this many of you know that we've been
writing for a long time pre-recession
about critical problems particularly
among a single and married black males
in New York City talking about the fact
that nearly fifty percent are not
currently in the workforce that this is
not a matter of the unemployment rate
this is the matter of people who are
still actively looking for work and when
you get to people who have given up in
one way or the others the numbers
skyrocket particularly for black men but
we've also recently come up with other
problems that we're going to have to
address as we want to get out of this
recession we recently issued a report on
something called GED a program that was
actually set up for returning veterans
after World War two who didn't want to
go back to high school and didn't want
to sit in a classroom at the little
desks after they fought for American
freedom that program that was for GIS
has morphed into
critical program to deal with
credentialing of workers in New York
City we now have about 1.1 million New
Yorkers who don't have a high school
diploma we have one of the worst the
worst GD passage rates in the nation we
also i regret to say have one of the
worst outcomes for our community college
system there are a whole range of issues
that were relying on here and we have to
be honest about some of the
disinvestment and failure to act
particularly focusing on low wage
workers and people who are not
necessarily on academic tracks but who
need in a globalized economy the kinds
of skills that at least we'll get them
into the door so they can feed
themselves and their families and I
think we can't be proud of how New York
is done on all we did a studying some
time ago and many of you know about on
Career and Technical Education again New
York that's okay it again last of the
nation we seemed to hit it not that
we're not a great city not that we don't
have incredible institutions like
Colombia and and NYU and the rest but
we've always given short shrift to
essentially programs for non academics
oh it doesn't matter they'll get some
kind of low-wage work it doesn't matter
will push them where they can drop out
of school it doesn't matter if they
don't come back and get their GED he'll
always be unskilled work well we're now
in an economy we're clearly what's
happening is this recession turns on
there is no low-wage work that people
are clamoring the joke is not so joke
that now starbucks is looking for people
with some years of college why because
they can get these people who needs a
youngster who draw who has a sixth grade
reading level who was pushed out or
dropped out when i can get somebody with
two or three years of college who's
clamoring for a what used to be a
low-wage job so i put this out not to
say or point a finger that way you know
this is a you know terrible what we can
do we have to wring our hands
to be done about it but at least we have
to reflect that as we talk about
infrastructure let's be honest that the
construction trades in the city of New
York have never hired blacks and Latinos
and significant numbers let's be honest
about that you hear that you know there
was 453 million dollars in stimulus
money that went to naija most of it did
not go to residents of naija we again
even though we have laws that are
promulgated out of HUD called section 3
we haven't traditionally spent a lot of
effort making sure that the tenants in
public housing got jobs or job training
that's changing but we have to look at
what's going to really impact not the
top end now now we have to focus on this
city starts to wobble if you have so
many people who are out of work who your
unemployment rates remain at the numbers
that we hit in the Great Depression
which is about twenty-five percent for
many communities where black and Latino
communities they're there but I don't
see WPA programs springing up because
everyone says the recession is over
whether that's all we need instinct to
us and infrastructure projects are
always not having any requirement
particularly to hire people at the
bottom even if it's a construction
project that's right in their community
so these are some of the things we have
to go on to but let me let me talk about
the positives and there are positives
out there and that's what I think is
more important and where I think we
should start attacking this thing that
broadens on many of the things that the
deputy mayor says but it are consistent
one of the things is we have to
recognize that transitional jobs and wpa
program kinds of models have to be had
in the city of New York to stabilize
this thing we have about 30,000 people
who were unemployed 16 to 24 just in
public housing I don't think this is a
good idea to have that large number of
people without skills from credential
sitting around staring out into space
long term because we know that one of
the dangers here
is our sick part are ten point six
percent unemployment people will begin
to give up everyone knows this if you're
out of work for two weeks that's one
thing if you're out of work for a year
that's quite another thing and as people
become further and further divorce from
the labor market the ability to reattach
them becomes that much more difficult so
the necessity has to be even though I
know it's oh this is too you know too
much money too much this and that we
have to think of techniques of giving
jobs of last resort I'm not talking
about great jobs necessarily to this
large body particularly the young and
the not so young and we'll talk about
that who are losing hope too quickly I
think it's dangerous to the city it's
Danebury dangerous to the civic life of
the city if that number continues to
grow and in bitter a whole generation of
young people I think we have to do
something there are some things you can
do and they've already been discussed
congressman rangel got a piece and the
stimulus that is just working its way
through regulation of a tax credit to
help private employers this is that
Kathy and I both worked on this that
would essentially give a large tax
credit to people young people who have
been out of work for six months out of
school for six months just to
incentivize private business to start
hiring that group on the infrastructure
side we worked with congressman nadler
who's put in a bill that would be
matched and and and linked up with the
transportation infrastructure but it
could be worked on any infrastructure
that creates model WPA programs where
teams of young people work together on
essentially infrastructure projects in
their thousands I think these are
projects that can be worked out Jerry
worked with the National Labor on this
to make sure it passed muster but I
think we have to innovate now and not
just think we got that infrastructure
dollars that's it we have to recognize
that ordinarily that infrastructure
money won't provide jobs to the
individuals who need it most and we have
to start working on that and engaging
that similarly we
and over a billion dollars on public
housing in the city of New York there's
something called section three that I
drive people crazy on I've been doing it
for a while which mandates that the
first hires of federal money of this
sort is supposed to go to the people who
are the residents of public housing or
the surrounding area this has been
abysmal Jen this is Democrat Republican
no one has enforced this to his credit
are Shaun Donovan from the city and
assistant secretary Kristina's has it
committed to enforcing section 3
regulations what that could mean if it
was seriously enforced would be
thousands of potential jobs for
particularly young people and not so
young people in public housing this is
not going to solve the recession I just
want to give some glimmers of hope for
people so they hold on while we wait
around for this recession and its
unemployment rate to obey all of these
projects obviously require political
will and that's one of the problems
we're having in Washington and obviously
everyone sees it New York City can only
do so much but New York City has to use
its position because this new york city
is not alone in this we did a report
some years ago by Mark Levitt on who's
now at the government city government
which showed that we have about 200,000
people 16 to 24 who were not in school
and not in work it was the highest
number I'd ever seen of that number
these are 16 to 24 year olds who never
connected why we can talk about but I
don't think it's relevant it turns out
that there were five million across the
nation not only in urban areas but in
servant suburban areas basically without
high school credentialing who just
couldn't get a toehold in the economy I
think we're going to have to look at the
disconnected youth because we have the
highest number of anywhere in the
country but we have ways to link hands
with other major cities they're having
the same problem whether that's detroit
or newark or you know LA each of them is
going to be facing after
this recession begins to rebait abate
large numbers of young people
particularly who are completely left
behind and don't have a reason to hang
in there I think we have to make common
cause with those but we have to be
realistic and talk seriously to the
construction trades and others that
we're going to have to allow certain
numbers of people a chance to get in at
the bottom in apprenticeship and
pre-apprenticeship programs if we're
going to hold this thing still we're not
talking about taking unionized jobs
we're talking about actively working
with the union movement and I think it
will take leadership from the mayor from
the governor and from the President to
get that done similarly we can't look at
summer jobs as quite the way they are
summer jobs are no longer just a frill
to keep people off the streets we
desperately need that this summer I
dread we have to make sure not only that
summer jobs so we maintain and they've
been cut in the first proposals coming
out of albany but we have to make sure
they're augmented because i can't go
through bedford-stuyvesant and Crown
Heights and Brownsville and the South
Bronx with this kind of unemployment
rate with no hope for young people doing
for simple things to do right away and I
talked about the educational programs we
have to make GED this is ridiculous I I
don't know why we're both below
Mississippi in GED we spend about 60
million in the state we have awful
outcomes we have awful awful outcomes
not only in city programs but in CUNY
programs though they do much better than
everywhere and we have HRA programs that
are not working we just have to take
this seriously this is blocking and
tackling this isn't new money this is
competence which this administration
does particularly well and I think we
just have to have the kind of focus to
make sure no one who touches the city
whether they are receiving food stamps
or going through a job center or going
into any contact doesn't come out with
at least or credential because they
can't compete going in this society
without that basic and credential
I think those are the kinds of things I
want to see I think what I'm concerned
about is as I hear the talk of recovery
it is again becoming too narrowly
focused it is not recognizing the nature
of this recession and who's gotten hurt
worst and who really in dangers the
fabric of New York once we get to that I
think we can all celebrate this stimulus
package was vitally necessary to hold us
from total disaster but is now we look
at it we have to recognize we have to
shift focus now away from Wall Street in
the banks to infrastructure yes but only
as it impacts not only making the city
better and look better but also start
bringing into the tent large number of
disaffected and alienated and outsiders
who are losing ground like crazy and who
are not participating in the recovery
and who may be permanently unemployed if
we don't move now thank you thank you
David I'm now going to ask Kathy wild 2
cloves with her final with the final
presentation Thank You Esther and Esther
came to work with us at the partnership
at the beginning of january and i was
our first project I'm up here working
for Esther but that will come as a
surprise a few of you and I would I
would I would I also just want to thank
mayor Dinkins for all the support he's
given all of us and I was reminded as
I'm sitting there and often am reminded
thinking about the challenges that we
face in our city and our country one of
the first things mayor Dinkins was asked
to do after his historic election as the
first african-american mayor of New York
City was deleted delegation shortly
after Nelson Mandela was released from
prison he led a delegation of about 30
of us and then they
haken Arnie cigar and some of us are
here that were on that trip too and it
was amazing because Mayor Dinkins went
through in these caravans through the
townships of South Africa and thousands
and thousands of people came out and in
the background with those yellow trucks
with the machine guns peeking out of
them that were still there at that time
I mean it was it was just an amazing
experience and when we think we face
challenges here I think we can all take
heart from the leadership that we are
lucky enough to have and what has been
accomplished so I'm pleased to be here
on the celebration of your anniversary
man I'm just going to make it you'll be
relieved to know I'm just going to make
a few points about the stimulus and the
economic situation which we find
ourselves on Tom Suozzi mentioned
earlier the fact that on average public
sector jobs are about ten percent of the
economy of our cities and states and
that the fact that the stimulus went
overwhelmingly to support and retain
public sector jobs in education in
health care some an infrastructure
Social Services was in fact important
not only for closing the budget gaps of
the city and state for stabilizing our
economy one thing I want to point out in
terms of the particular challenges in
new york in new york north of rockland
county it's not ten percent of the jobs
the public sector is twenty percent of
the jobs and that's why our taxes are so
high in New York City and Long Island so
so the the challenge here was number one
I mean the good news and the bad news is
the stimulus was more important to New
York State than to any place and we got
something like 20 billion and that
really saved our state budget last year
but at the same time it reflects a
structural problem we'll have going
forward where if we don't turn from
simply filling the gaps in our public
sector economy to growing our private
sector
me we are in deep trouble this year we
only have four and a half billion left
from that 20 billion to apply to this
year's deficit which is on and so we
still have a hole on top of that of 7.4
billion in the new york in new york
state budget so we have huge issues
facing us that are a big challenge and
we're going to continue to need federal
support that's why the continuation of
the kind of assistance we got for
education and medicaid through the
federal government through some of those
formulas adjusted to reflect the
realities of our needs are very
important going forward we can't just
say the stimulus is over and let's move
on the other thing about this stimulus
was um that I think you know in the gap
that everybody's struggling with is
we've put out all this money and yet our
unemployment rate is high our economy at
the fourth quarter of the year our gdp
was up to five point seven percent the
news has just come out and it feels like
that sounds like wow the gdp increase
was largely a reflection of productivity
the fact that business had laid off many
hundreds of millions of people and they
were able to do more with less and
that's our economic gain so this is the
gap between the numbers about the
economy and how good it appears things
are doing and the reality of this
continuing growing chronic now gap in
terms of translating translating that
into jobs another example 90 billion
dollars of the stimulus funding went
into the department of energy for grants
and renewable energy and to create
leadership in this area and we're all
supportive of that on average when a new
industry is started up whether it's
biotech or high-tech it takes 15 years
before that translates into net new jobs
and revenues and we're just starting in
the renewable energy field maybe we're
three or four years into it we've got a
long ways to go before we're going to
feel that coming back into our economy
and that is a real challenge on the in
New York City again as Bob gave a number
of the of the statistics in terms of of
the economy thirty percent of the
payroll in New York City comes out of
the financial services industry it's
only twelve percent of the jobs but
thirty percent of all the payroll
dollars which is I think three times
greater than any other sector it's a
it's a huge piece of our economy and
there is no great world city in the 21st
century global economy that is not a
financial center we cannot afford to
lose that for those who think well who
are worried about what we spent on the
tarp program in fact the taxpayers are
getting a very handsome return on their
tarp investments where we're losing
boatloads is on the car companies and
even though all the legislation coming
out of Washington says let Main Street
pay for Wall Street fiscal
responsibility repayment fees in fact
the banking industry is going to
handsomely repay the taxpayer with
interest and it is not something that we
should feel is a bailout that's a
bottomless pit we are in fact
demonstrating the resilience of our
industry so the last person standing to
defend the banking industry Here I am
what is our challenge going forward it
is uncertainty lack of clear vision I'm
the American consumer the president is
in his in his budget plan and his
economic plan is getting incentives to
the to the middle class tax payer well
that's okay but it's not going to turn
our economy around quickly because the
middle-class tax payer is about as
insecure as you can get major
corporations are about as insecure as
you can get they are not feeling
comfortable about what's going to happen
in the economy because we are
shell-shocked by what's happened in the
last two years that nobody expected to
happen number one number two we're not
sure how we're going to deal with the
competitive pressures the American
he is not a source of growth in terms of
its future contribution it's the
emerging economies from Asia and Africa
and around the world that are the source
of future growth and we have to figure
out how to service those economies the
president in his address also said the
goal is to double exports in the next
five years absolutely critical because
we're not going to grow the economy
domestically we are going to have to
grow through international exports and
that is obviously heavily comes down on
services and the question is what are
they what are we going to do and there's
no clear plan we don't have an economic
development corporation or a deputy
mayor for economic development at the
federal level we don't have a clear plan
for how we're going to integrate the
expenditures in energy and in education
and in all these areas and flow them
back into a strategic plan for building
the American economy for competing
overseas other countries do and they pay
attention certainly to their great
business cities and capitals they invest
in it they think about it some would say
they over plan but we think I think that
one thing we have to do is think in
terms of the next iteration what comes
after stimulus what comes after bailout
it is a strategic plan for going forward
on a variety of fronts some of which
David mentioned and and some of which
Bob mentioned in terms of our economy so
I guess those are my thoughts trying to
see if I have anything else I think
that'll do it thank
thank you all very much that was just
extremely provocative and creative and
hoping we have some questions from the
group here if you want please stand up
at the mic maybe we have a little Wilder
question hi it's hard to connect the
deputy mayor's remarks with David but
i'm going to try because you talked
about small businesses identify yourself
thank you or I will Nancy wax Jean I'm
the executive director of United
neighborhood houses and a former member
of the Lincoln's administration the you
talked about small businesses in fact we
know that I think the mayor said that
nonprofit businesses or employ one
seventh of New York City's people but
yet when we talk about supporting small
businesses very often nonprofits are
left out of that equation and they have
the same problems of access to credit in
the same problems of health insurance
soaring health insurance costs so I'm
wondering what you see is the role of
the city and supporting nonprofits
interconnected to David's remarks weed
in the nonprofit community are the ones
who are most likely to employ
entry-level people low skilled people
give them their first step on the
employment ladder give them a chance
maybe starting and after-school programs
or wherever to get into the workforce so
i would say that we have a role in
addressing both of those problems and
but yet i haven't seen the same
recognition of the importance of the
nonprofit sector in this in the cities
of planning okay i'm going to just ask
you to answer that question that i'm
going to take two at a time okay one of
the things that we saw for small
businesses that is similar to the
not-for-profits again as the lack of
financing the banks just drawing in any
of the funding that they were going to
provide one of our programs I talked
about it in the context of the small
businesses but we also were working with
not-for-profits and with the banks as
well so our capital access a program was
really designed to work
banks and say will absorb a first
percentage of the risk associated with
making these kinds of loans and that
would apply to a business or
not-for-profit so we're not trying to
choose and make that selection because
the not-for-profits play an incredibly
important part of role in the economy
overall I think to David's point on the
the workforce training and the the most
necessary component that the economy's
one of the things that we are working
very hard at work force one training is
taking people who are unemployed or
underemployed and trying to provide that
the necessary skills and and Retraining
so that they'll be able to come out with
with a degree i think the degree program
the vocational and those are all very
very important parts of trying to build
out that the middle class part of the
economy here and that's why we were
actually pretty happy to see the success
we add you know increasing by again by
over thirty percent the number of people
we were actually able to place out of
work force one centers in one hand it
was twenty-five thousand verses 17
thousand the year before on the one hand
it's 25,000 we've got a lot more that
we're trying to do and that's we're
trying to model with the successes we've
had particularly around these sector
initiatives to try and target those
opportunities with the people who need
those jobs do you want to comment David
on the same vein I mean one of the
things we failed at in terms of the tax
credit that Kathy and I worked on with
congressman rangel was a transferable
tax credit and this idea has been around
for 20 years actually Ford Foundation
did some of the initial work it
ultimately failed because the Internal
Revenue Service said that was not the
Congressional intent essentially a cash
credit credit would work the same as a
housing tax credit is that you could
essentially allow a transferable tax
credit involving a not-for-profit that
could then sell those tax credits to
pepsico or coca-cola or a corporation
who needed a tax credit it runs into
severe issues I think however that
because of the depth of this recession
and because of the lack of real
opportunities to get the the job motor
going
that we're starting to think again that
it may be time to revisit this with ways
and means if you're not going to come up
with stimulus two and three whether you
can come up with novel ideas using the
tax code partially because we have the
head of the ways and means but I think
we have to be a little more innovative
here and coming up with ideas of how
not-for-profits could participate in
some of the stimulus effort Oh Cathy who
also managed not-for-profits I I was
just going to say and this may be more
productive octave than necessary but the
the city makes an enormous investment
through our property tax laws in
not-for-profits but it's not for profits
that are real estate intensive as
opposed to service intensive and I think
that's something that you have to stand
back and think about thank you I'm gonna
stoop that's why I Daniela queen here
we're going to protect her I'm going to
take two questioners at a time please be
succinct and then we're going to ask the
panel to respond this way we can get to
everybody my question has to do Oh
related to david jones offer so thank
you for being steward for the voiceless
out there those in most need I think
you're familiar with you feel USA and I
understand that in Obama's proposed
budget it's at 120 million up 414 right
what's your take on that model for young
men and women between the ages of 18 24
who fit exactly the profile you're
talking about we're going to hold up one
more question I'm an alumnus of columbia
college class of nineteen fifty-nine
in my 50 years of observing society I
come to the conclusion we seem to be
going around in circles because in order
to function in the 21st century every
individual must have computer skills and
I would think that a massive education
program to teach everyone who is out of
a job to learn how to use a computer
would be quite beneficial to society
thank you do you folks there okay what
let's do one more hi my name is moralo
sleep wanna thank you very much for a
wonderful panel I am a student dual
degree masters here in Columbia I am
actually a student from Mayor Dinkins
and my question is on the tax credits
how are you going to prevent that
employers that are struggling will not
let people go in order to hire those
employees that will provide them with
the tax credits you get my problem thank
you those are all very good questions
why don't we start uh David Kathy and
let me take a last question i'll try to
do very simply essentially what the
Internal Revenue Service is slowing this
whole process down for is the quick
question of employers gaming the system
it is a danger that has to be highly
regulated in order to work but it also
has to be done in a way that can get it
to small smaller employers essentially
the people who you make use of tax
credits the best for instance PepsiCo is
that the largest user of tax credits
they know about it generally when it
drills down to smaller employers the
paperwork burden is much too high for
them to make use of it and we have to
figure intermediaries out who can both
police this thing to make sure we're not
having a game system that basically
bumps employees out and then puts
lower-cost employers in at the same time
making it transparent easy to use so
that's that's that's one thing let me
talk about youth build we are in
discussion with youth build actually
about can
the youth build model be brought to
scale the I drive people crazy I when I
was youth service Commissioner or
executive director whatever we called at
the time we had so much I think we still
have so many models of programs that
work the problem that drives me crazy
there never scale when you have this
many unemployed then boys excited
blowing them it means that a program
that serves two or three hundred people
is not sufficient for a full-employment
economy that it's a great program for an
economy in the midst of this employment
meltdown we only can start to talk about
programs that impact thousands and
that's why the question can you come to
the city and make marriages of
not-for-profits and and for profits and
a government that deal with mass based
programs we've done this before in the
past the gentleman before was talking
about we're coming full circle teams of
people working on critical projects
actually we've have examples in the city
of that but i think the youth build
model we're certainly having discussions
with nijah and others that we can't
expect certain parts of government to
know how to do youth we have to marry
not-for-profits and organizations that
actually do this kind of work and can
scale it and can scale it not over years
but can scale scale it within a
reasonable time to give hope the I think
tax credits are hard but I don't know if
there's an op-ed last week in the Sunday
Times the Chuck Schumer and Orrin Hatch
co-signed on a proposal that I think
makes sense which is a rebate to
employers at the end of the year of net
new payroll taxes added for new hires on
jobs and that's a lot easier to monitor
and I think makes a lot more sense and
that's similar to what governor
Patterson has introduced in his
Excelsior program the economic
development where where it is after the
fact the job is created its net new jobs
and the credit is directly related to
the value the quality of the job
provided I guess the two things one is
the
on the tax credits I think it the you
know they it's all in the execution and
I think that David makes the point in
Kathy reinforces that you have to be
careful for what you really do and
having the enforcement and getting the
right kind of behavior that comes out of
this what is critical I think on the
computer skills thing I couldn't agree
with you more it's like basic 101 and
that's one of the things that we also
not that to bang the drum again but on
the workforce one training centers that
we provide the training and we also
provide the facilities for people who
don't have their own computers who need
to be able to access that get on the
internet or be able to use those just
basic technology is a critical critical
factor at anyone moving forward today we
have time for two more questions perfect
hi I'm at all in the elevator my name is
Gwyneth fries and I'm a masters of
international affair student who were
the focus and urban policy I wanted to
share with you that it seems to me being
a graduate student that the credentials
that you need to be competitive in
today's labor market are getting more
and more expensive and frankly I'm not
completely convinced that apprenticeship
programs and GED programs are going to
be sufficient to prepare people to to
access a decent living how would you
respond to that concern thank you yes
good afternoon my name is Gerard boo
shell and I in the financial services
industry one of the questions that I
have is that there is an explicit
tension that seems to continue to
manifest when we talk about where are
the opportunities and what I'd like for
you to address is the first how do we
structure or at least facilitate having
a flexible economy that will facilitate
the efficient allocation of capital
because first and foremost you don't
have to do business in New York City
okay that's number one and then
simultaneously resolve the other issue
of the tension the social tension that
is very explicit how do you find or move
capital and opportunities to those
communities that are impaired
terms of being effectively marginalized
out because that is always the question
so when we talk about New York City yes
it is an outlier in terms of inequality
that's a very simple proposition but
there is a multiplier effect that does
feed all right through the economy so
then the question is when you talk about
the construction trades as an example
their jobs that clearly people of color
are not getting access to so when we
talk about creating particular types of
local programs not certain that's always
the answer given the fact that
historically they've been excluded so
then the question is how do you resolve
this issue of making an economy flexible
but also ensuring that social needs are
met in a very fair and open way to
really bring people here to do business
thank you why don't we start first with
deputy mayor Lieber and work our way
back thanks Esther how do I want to
respond to that I guess what I would say
first of all is that you know on the
education question I think that skills
and increased levels of skill or going
to be critical to anyone's ability to
succeed in this world it's also going to
require lots of hard work I think that's
kind of fundamental to everything and I
think the minimum kind of level of
education what David talks about just
say 1.1 million people don't have g d's
don't have a GED I mean that's that
really is kind of that's really brutal
and you think about a college education
now by and large it's kind of being the
base level of training for people as
they move forward to have that high
level of not people don't even have a
higher education is a real problem and I
think he identifies that issue so I
think you know keep going to school do
well but get out you have to work and
make some money to as you do it on the
second part on the creating the
opportunities I think part of what we're
trying to do is you know I New York is
not necessarily going to be the lowest
cost place for people to do business you
say you don't have to do business in New
York City's that's true people who do
business in New York City do it in New
York City because they want to do it I
think our competitive advantage is the
talent and the people that we do have in
New York City by and large and one
the things that we're trying to do is to
be a convener to try and keep people
here in the city and find opportunities
for them to to match needs and to match
opportunities as we go one of the other
things though in to David's point
earlier about the MWBE hiring and how
poor the unions take up has been on this
one of the things that we've done that
hasn't really gotten a lot of fanfare as
renegotiated a contract with the unions
and a project labor agreement for city
projects city capital funded projects
here and we have the biggest issue that
we had and wrestling what the unions are
the most important issue for us was
trying to improve this take up in MWBE
hiring so before was something like one
and eight they got hired out of a union
hall we have changed those numbers
dramatically so there's that I can't
recite the exact formula but that you
know multiple three or four times as
many people will have this opportunity
to get picked up and as a requirement
here that as the unions pick people or
contractors pick people to do the work
that they're picking from an MBE pool as
well that will hopefully see a
significant take up in what has been an
otherwise relatively dismal performance
by the unions to hire people and give
them jobs as they come out of it so
another important part of what we're
trying to do Cathy I'm taking the
college thing which I I don't want
anyone to think that I don't agree with
the trouble is I'm in sort of an
emergency I think before we started
doing our in-depth research on this
1,000,000 one on black male unemployment
on disconnected youth I had an inflated
notion of the educational levels that we
were dealing with weird however we have
really a huge educational deficit that
we're up against I think in the mayor's
construction opportunity panel that I
served on some you know with congressman
Rangel with the mayor put together one
of the real difficulties we had started
this effort really to deal with
disconnected youth it soon became
apparent that for most
pre-apprenticeship programs in the city
of New York for the trades requires a
high school diploma but the people
coming forward we're often reading at a
6th to 8th grade
level and numerous even less and this is
no joke this this means i don't have a
quick fix to bring people back on in a
line but i think we have to start
working on it and that's what gets me so
agitated that we haven't looked at the
resources around GED and other efforts
to try to take the first step once
people can get stabilized and have that
first credential and we find that in the
CUNY programs particularly cutie gives a
GD is just as a path that's part of the
course you get a GD on your way to an
associate's degree their passage rate on
GD goes through the roof because of it
we also find that we can get incredible
GED passage rates of the people in
incarcerated they have one of the
highest passage rates because they are
very focused but I just think the
contact points have to be serious this
has to be first up not jobs first as we
still have the idea that everyone had to
be forced to work because they were
sitting on their rear ends and not
working I think we have to do an
analysis which gets people who are
seeking support and immediately does a
serious assessment of their educational
attainment and yes you get them working
but you also immediately start working
on their skills because that's the only
way you can start to reduce the burden
on government and that's what I'm
talking about this is not the end and
basically we know that once people
achieve a GED once people achieve an
associate degree then they take off like
a big-ass bird they don't need any of us
to help them along they know what they
want okay I think I just say quickly on
the question the economy I think every
generation has to see this for
themselves but for those of us that have
been through a couple generations mayor
Koch and Mayor Dinkins led a economic
Renaissance in the neighborhoods of our
city between 1975 and 1995 the the
investment the change the hope the
quality of housing and infrastructure in
the communities of this city was just it
just
in the most dramatic way demonstrating
that where there is the political will
in leadership there is in fact the way
in our system works that's a perfect
note to end this particular part of our
forum I just want to thank our three
panelists who were really terrific and
from now I get to call up our very own
Mayor David Dinkins to close the form
well those there's some people here in
this audience who with whom I have
worked overtime and so they know all my
material and they and so mark monoi you
will recognize this early on is that
well that's no Johnstown Flood fits it
really does fit you see in 1889 there
was a high John Doe in 1889 there was a
flood in Johnstown Pennsylvania the damn
above the town gave way and waters came
down and a lot of people lost their
lives there were those that clung to a
wooden railroad trestle and thought that
they might be saved but debris piled up
along the trestle friction caused the
fire and they too perished well a man
survived all this lived to be a hundred
and five and he found that in heaven he
went to heaven because he was a good
person he found out that it was the
custom in heaven to come forth and tell
of a momentous event in your life and he
knew that he would be an instant
celebrity in heaven for after all he had
survived the mighty Johnstown Flood so
ultimately his turn came and he strode
down the center aisle toward the lectern
confident that in seconds everyone in
heaven would know who he was for after
all he'd survived the mighty Johnstown
Flood this tragedy of immense proportion
as he passed an angel reached out and
touched him on the shoulder and said I
think you should know
that Noah is in the audience some of you
will get that on your way home the point
is that we have had eight Noah's eight
Noah's here today and I hope you feel as
privileged as I do that they've come
forth and given of themselves in his
fashion and I want to conclude this by
making this observation when I was
privileged to serve this city as mayor
not infrequently the press would
surround me and fire questions and I'd
give what i thought was an appropriate
in response and then they would say well
you mean in other words and my response
was no not in other words in the words
I've just given you so you will not get
a summation from me there will be no
other words these are the words thanks
for coming